Some of my Republican friends
want to take the economy hostage.
I get it.
Unless I agree to their economic plans.
All of you
at home should know what those plans are.
Instead of making the wealthy pay
their fair share, some Republicans,
some Republicans
want Medicare and Social Security sunset.
I'm not saying it's a majority of
let me give you.
Anybody who doubts
contact my office.
I'll give you a copy.
I'll give you a copy of the proposal.
That means Congress doesn't vote
or I'm glad to see.
And I tell you, I enjoy conversion
You know, amazing.
If Congress doesn't keep the programs
the way they are,
they'd go way other Republicans say.
I'm not saying it's a majority of you.
I don't even think it's even
a significant
what is being proposed by individuals.
I'm not politely not naming them,
but as being proposed by some of you.
Folks.
The idea is that we're not going to be
we're not going to be moved
into being threatened
to default on the debt
if we don't respond.
Both
so folks,
as we all apparently agree,
Social Security,
Medicare, is off of the books now
and they're not going to strike.
All right.
Ready?
We've got unanimity
Social Security, Medicare,
a lifeline for millions of seniors.
Americans have to pay into them
from the very first paycheck
they've started.
So tonight, let's all agree.
I'm afraid we are a stand up for seniors
Stand up and show them
will not cut Social Security
We will not cut Medicare.
Those benefits
belong to the American people.
They earned it.
And if anyone tries
to cut Social Security,
which apparently no one's going to do
and if anyone tries it from Medicare,
I'll stop them.
I'll veto it.
No, I'm not going to allow them
to take away
be taken away
not today, not tomorrow, not ever.
But apparently it's
not going to be a problem.
Next month.
When I offer my fiscal plan,
I ask my Republican friends
to lay down their plan as well.
Yes, I really mean it.
Let's sit down together
and discuss our mutual plans together.
Let's do that.
I can tell you
the plan I'm going to show,
you're going to cut the deficit
by another $2 trillion
and I won't cut a single bit of Medicare
or Social Security.
In fact,
we're going to extend the Medicare
trust fund at least two decades
because that's going to
be the next target.
How do we make keep it solvent? Right.
Well,
we'll not raise taxes on anyone
making under 400 grand, but
we'll pay for it
the way we
talked about tonight
by making sure that the wealthy
and big corporations
pay their fair share.
Look, look, look.
Here's the deal.
They're just taking advantage
of the tax code.
They're taking advantage
of the American consumer.
Here's my message
to all of you out there.
I have your back.
We're already preventing Americans
receiving surprise medical bills,
stopping $1 billion surprise
bills per month so far.
For protecting
seniors life savings
by cracking down on nursing homes
that commit fraud and danger patient
safety, prescribed drugs
that are not needed.
Millions of Americans can now
save thousands of dollars
because they can finally get
a hearing aid over-the-counter
without a prescription.
Look,
capitalism
without competition is not capitalism.
It's extortion.
It's exploitation.
Last year,
I cracked down on behalf of many of you
on foreign shipping companies
that were making you
pay higher prices
for every good coming into the country.
I signed a bipartisan bill
to cut shipping costs
by 90%,
helping American
farmers, businessmen and consumers.
Let's finish the job.
Passed the bipartisan legislation
to strengthen
our strategy, strengthen
antitrust enforcement
and for banks, and prevent
big online platforms
giving their own products
an unfair advantage.
My administration is
also taking on junk fees those hidden
surcharges to many companies use
to make you pay more.
For example,
we're making airlines
show you the full ticket price upfront.
Refund your money
if your flight is canceled or delayed.
We reduce exorbitant bank overdraft
by saving consumers more than $1 billion
a year for cutting credit card late fees
by 75% from $30 to $8
Wolf,
junk fees
may not matter to the very wealthy,
but they matter to most
other folks in homes
like the one I grew up in,
like many of you did.
They add up to hundreds of dollars
a month.
They make it harder for you
to pay your bills
or afford that family trip.
I know how unfair it feels
when a company overcharges
you to gets away with it. Not anymore.
We've written a bill to stop it all.
It's called the Junk Fee Prevention Act.
If we're going to ban
surprise resort fees
that hotels charge are now on your bill.
Those fees can cost up to $90
a night in hotels
that aren't even resorts
with the idea
that cable, internet
and cell phone companies
can charge you 200 or more.
If you decide
to switch to another provider,
give me a break.
We can stop service fees on tickets
to concerts
and sporting events
and make companies disclose
all the fees upfront.
And we'll prohibit airlines
from charging $50
roundtrip for family
just to be able to sit together.
Baggage fees are bad enough
Airlines can't treat your child
like a piece of baggage.
Americans are tired of being poor, tired
of being played for suckers.
So past
pass the Junk Fee Prevention Act.
So companies stop ripping us off.
For too long,
workers have been getting stiffed,
but not anymore.
We're
beginning to restore the dignity of work.
For example,
I should have known this,
but I didn't until two years ago.
30 million workers
have to sign non-compete agreements
with the jobs they take.
30 million.
So a cashier
at a burger place can't walk across town
and take the same job
in another burger place
and make a few bucks more.
Just change.
But I just changed because we exposed it.
That was part of the deal.
Guys, look it up.
But not anymore.
Everybody knows agreements,
so companies have to compete for workers
and pay them what they're worth.
And I must tell you,
this is
bound to get a response from my friends
on my left.
But the right.
I'm so sick and tired of companies
breaking the law
by preventing workers
from organizing pass the Pro Act,
because businesses that are right
workers have a right to form a union
less guarantee
all workers have a living wage.
Let's make sure working parents
can afford to raise a family
with sick days, paid family
medical leave, affordable child care,
that's
going to enable millions
of more people to go and stay at work.
And let's restore
the full child tax credit
which gave tens of millions of parents
some breathing room
and cut child poverty in half
to the lowest level in history.
And by the way,
when we do all these things,
we increase productivity.
We increase economic growth.
So let's finish the job
and get more families
access to affordable, quality housing.
Let's get seniors
who want to stay in their homes,
the care they need to do so.
Let's give more breathing room
to millions of family caregivers
looking after their loved ones
past my plan.
So we get seniors
and people with disabilities,
the home care and services they need
to support
the workers who are doing God's work
These plans are fully paid for,
and we can afford to do them.
Restoring the dignity of work means
making education
an affordable ticket to the middle class.
You know,
when we made public education
12 years of a universal
in the last century,
we made the best educated, best paid.
We became the best educated,
best paid nation in the world.
The rest was caught up.
It caught up.
Joel, my wife, who teaches full time
as an expression
I hope I get it right, kid.
Any nation of our educators
is going to outcompete us.
Any nation, outeducate,
can outcompete us.
Folks, we all know 12 years of education
is not enough to win
the economic competition of 21st century
You want to have the
best educated workforce.
Let's finish the job
by providing access to free school
for 34 year olds.
Studies show that children
who go to
preschool are nearly 50%
more likely to finish high school
and go on to a two or four year degree,
no matter their background.
That came from let's get public school.
Teachers are raised